well got an early morning call again
this morning at about six o'clock when
um some
artillery noises were heard here in the
center we know that there has been
shelling and explosions uh wider afield
probably about 10 kilometers away from
where we are now an area that we went to
yesterday as well as a lot of um
explosions and what appears to be
fighting around the suburbs primarily
those of european butcher hostimal and
garenka those areas that we you've seen
so much of over the past few days but
because of the curfew the outside here
and the streets of of the capital are
absolutely deadly quiet if you come a
bit closer i'll show you what the
streets look like and you can see that
there is no one moving at all at the
moment and we were told by
the mayor that one of the reasons for
this very strict and dramatic curfew
that those vehicles that you'll be
seeing will be
possibly unmarked or
emergency vehicles or unmarked uh
security vehicles but
we were told by the mayor that this very
strict curfew was because they
anticipated so much more
activity from the russians in particular
they're worried about
uh russian saboteurs who possibly made
their way into
the center of the capital or the
outskirts uh we spoke to the female
commander of one of these units who are
trying to track down russian saboteurs
and and she was saying their modus
operandi was making marks around the
city which were be they believed were
being used to
guide
the russian
attackers the russian air strikes
russian drones russian explosions to
certain targets they were also leaving
identify identification marks around the
city for them the saboteurs to be picked
up and they were finding this as they
were tracking down the russian saboteurs
but the the mayor uh was very um
concerned about this being a pivotal
moment a dangerous moment and he very
much appealed to
kiev
residents to take cover to take shelter
those who've already been hit over the
past 48 hours
the ones that we spoke to anyway were
not just shocked they were also there
was a growing anger and a real
determination to hold out and we know
having spoken to the president's chief
of staff that while negotiations seem to
be making some headway with the
president hinting that there may be um
room for negotiations on both sides with
him saying that the russians seem to be
more realistic in their demand we've
spoken to the president's chief of staff
before the curfew and he very much said
there were red lines that they would not
be prepared to cross and that was they
were wanting to defend every bit of
territory including those that had
already been taken over by the russians
over the past eight years